homelessness isn't just about sleeping
rough Rising housing costs means that
more and more people are simply unable
to afford their rent and they're
applying to their local councils as
homeless but our analysis of the most
recent data suggests that often people
are being re-housed far far away from
the places they call home
so this is it this is where we leave
yeah how long have you been here for
um here it's been like um 18 months I
think so 19 months yeah
um but with the council in total is
about nearly four years now four years
from place to place yeah place to place
Mobility Kaba was living in central
London when she applied as homeless to
her Council four years ago
she and her three children have been
moved three times each time further away
from where she calls home I don't want
to stay here my kids don't want to stay
here that is even the reason they don't
want to change school because they don't
have trust in the system they don't know
where they're going to go maybe they'll
go further down maybe they'll go closer
we just want stability I mean if you had
to sum all that up what would you say
the effects being on you and your family
emotional is emotional breakdown you
don't have a life you've been control
you can't do anything you can't plan
my kids don't do activities no more they
they've been cut off from from the
health network All Families we don't
have family here so mostly we stuck
inside here mobility and her family were
sent to a different local Authority
still inside London but others are being
relocated much further away to
completely different regions
new analysis by the Sky News data team
shows that the number of homeless
households in England relocated outside
their home region has almost doubled
over the last three years
we found that the steepest rise was in
the East Midlands in 2019 approximately
only one in a hundred placements were
outside the region today that number is
closer to one in ten
many more households are given
accommodation in a different local
Authority but still in the same region
like mabinty in 2018 to 19 8.8 percent
of placements were in a different local
Authority last year that went up to 11.6
percent
and campaigners warn the problem is only
likely to get worse it's almost like a
perfect storm so you know we had a
pre-existing housing emergency we've
been going backwards in terms of
delivery of social homes for years
people are being hit by the cost of
living crisis and of course that means
that people are even less likely to be
able to afford their rent mabinty and
her children were already caught in that
storm tossed from one Council to another
the clouds could be gathering for many
more Tom Cheshire Sky News South London